[Music]
emergency crews in california launched a
rescue attempt recently
using four-wheelers a drone engines and
a truck oh that sounds fun find a guy
who who
was in the search party
this is normal she's pretty cold
they
rush to save a mannequin that looked
like he was
hanging off the side of a cliff wait who
[ __ ] who put it there
[ __ ] put that that's actually funny as
[ __ ] it's kind of creepy too so in santa
barbara county fire officials started
receiving calls about someone stranded
30 feet down a cliff just before 4 pm on
october 4th [ __ ] people passing by on
hope ranch beach saw the figure and
called for help i mean i guess you know
it does look like a person that does
they've been there for eight hours
not even moved yeah just
super secret things very strong
not even turning their head around going
hell
they're not responding to any of us
they're like why is this why is this
person's thermals really really lukewarm
what if they're dead already yeah what
if they're dead
rick or mortis to set in
we have to retrieve the body dude that
is that's gotta be against rigor morris
like you already know you like have to
step back feel like death phase he likes
the rigor like slide his sleeves down
and just [ __ ] jacked for
dude how pissed were the [ __ ]
firefighters that picked up the chick
and was like oh [ __ ] that's just a
mannequin
well basically it was one of those uh
and you know i must quote on this better
to call than not yeah type that's true
that's true yeah because what if it was
a real person everyone was like ah it's
just a mannequin like fall started
throwing rocks at it see if it would hit
it's just another mannequin honey
i mean it is santa barbara right yeah
so there's not much going on yeah they
could have saved the drowning surfer but
they they spent all the resources on
this mannequin so where the actual uh
the mannequin actually came from was
there was a movie shoot days prior oh
they left it there just left the
mannequin there dude that production is
getting [ __ ]
or they're getting free marketing no
they're getting [ __ ] [ __ ]
because the [ __ ] the government is
going to be like here's the [ __ ] bill
bro
for sure for sure yeah because they know
that they thing's got money and
insurance that it's not like milking how
much do you think that's gonna cost at
least thirty thousand dollars if not
thirty thousand dollars unless they were
a bunch of tubers because i remember we
shot something for jk for one of our old
skits and went to art center and there's
that bridge
we launched a mannequin
bridge too and we filmed it multiple
times because we needed to show like a
human jumping off a building
and then we just ran after wait how many
times did you do this i think we should
we got maybe a good maybe three to five
three to five tanks why so many takes
you had to like run it back up yeah
bang it out real quick like the wig fell
off oh [ __ ] it was a real mannequin like
a heavy mannequin oh it was like feel it
was like cotton but filled with like it
was it was it was steve standing all the
way there
damn they made that mannequin that's
funny just launched it off the bridge
because we couldn't afford one yeah at
the time so yeah the story was like if
we get stopped we're gonna get the
student film okay and everyone's alright
cool it's like that's a student film
i feel like we use the student film
excuse until our 30s honestly i still
use it for time time you should still
use it because then it's more depressing
yeah it's like hey it's a student film
i'm 35 years old
it's been this is my last chance
i've had a rough go yeah trying to get
my high school diploma
please they said so i just i'm just
curious about the pricing on this
multi-agency response with utvs drone
and a truck
that's you think that's only 30 000 or
more what they yeah
yeah they they take the whatever the
amount of money is that they paid all
those guys and they just go here's like
how much is a [ __ ] airlift out of
somewhere right that's at least like
five five grand or more right and so
then you've got all this other [ __ ] and
all these other people involved how much
is it when a [ __ ] ambulance comes
right a couple things
10k [ __ ] i don't know it's a lot pancake
i'm [ __ ] i remember in high school so
this was like 2002 2003 me and my buddy
got into a really bad accident uh in
montebello
and
uh our car knocked over one of the
street lights
and then that was eight g's from the
city that was the build then
and then just to fix the uh pole right
yeah and then the the jaws of life being
whatever came and opened the corridor to
pull both of us out and the ambulance
ride from montebello to sc which is
pretty close that was 500 bucks yeah and
then i think it was um
almost a thousand dollars per night at
sc county dude have you seen ambulances
fill up though at the gas station they
use the premium that's expensive
that's not that's not coming cheap i
heard something from a thousand bucks
and up is like the starting i think it
depends probably yeah i was just reading
about the mo there are cost effective
means of providing ambulance service and
those are private ambulance uh yeah it's
called uber
call [ __ ] uber i'm having a heart
attack i'm just having a heart attack
though i'll call that one no no i can't
afford that go over dude when i was here
and i i didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on i drove myself to the place
because i'm like i'm not [ __ ] but you
you left really quickly and we were all
like should he should he have driven not
only did you not not only did you drive
yourself you didn't even [ __ ] drive
to a close urgent care he didn't he went
to the one that he's used to yeah in
traffic god damn right i did because i i
was like okay here's the thing sold my
car for crypto so if nicki needed to
come to me i wanted to make it easy on
her
you wanted it to be easy for her to pick
up your body
identify my body
because of this move
she's gonna make her go out of the way
to identify the dental records here she
don't even need to see you she'll be
like i see that burnt terra hat exactly
how many tera hats are there in the
world even where did you even get it
yeah exactly i bought this on amazon oh
i made this
can you get more terra merch i think we
should all rock it dude i'm gonna get
some you guys want some i think it's a
terrible i'll just buy you something if
you want
i love the hands he's just jittery he's
like i'm in this video where i'm going
cards let's go i'll use ust let's go
passively
there's definitely i've randomly seen
like memes or [ __ ] like that on
instagram or whatever where it's kind of
like you know something happened to me
checked into the hospital for the night
suddenly i have like a 200 000 build
that's exactly the same my mom broke her
leg when i was in fairfax virginia when
i was a kid and i'll never forget when
they got the ambulance bill was like 5
000 and that was back then 1995. wow
crazy and so yeah and the hospital's
right down the street we live by george
mason university it's like we're right
by the hospital that's crazy is it that
expensive because the insurance takes
care of everything because i don't know
why
that the ambulance is so damning it's
all [ __ ] sham dude and then they and
the ambulance drivers they get paid
[ __ ] like nine bucks an hour dude
it's so crazy
especially like the private emts because
i remember i was gonna try to be an emt
after college and uh i took a course and
i found out how much they got paid and i
was like yo why this is not even worth
it like i'm dealing with people's lives
here for like [ __ ] nine bucks an hour
it's everyone's worst day of their life
when i meet them exactly every day of my
job dude the horror stories you hear
from other emts and like other
paramedics
so [ __ ] up that makes you not want to
do it ten dollars an hour hell no yeah
bro oh
but when you work for the fire
department apparently that's like when
it's worth it but yeah that's when it
pays off but even the stories you get
from that are like
like one of my clients he was a
paramedic and he would this is gonna be
[ __ ] really [ __ ] up and really dark
but we're going down that way anyway and
that's what we got anyways exactly right
so this [ __ ] would tell me he
would go to someone's house and somebody
would run out with their
with their drowned child
like it's already drowned and either
like please like do what you can to save
my child and he's just like
we're gonna do what we can and he they
already know like mentally like this is
it like there's nothing we could do yeah
and imagine doing that for the rest of
your [ __ ] doing that just for bedside
happens so much and what they do is
round kids dude yeah and they go to an
orphanage and then they get a kid that
looks just like that kid and then they
just do a little swap do a swap yeah
like he's alive they take the orphanage
and they drown him just to show them
we're like we're going to drown in more
kids sometimes they have to dye their
hair to match like might be acting a
little different because he was drowned
but as you can see he's very wet so he's
definitely your kid have you guys heard
about that that uh it was a documentary
about it where they said this guy they
had one of their kids went missing oh
yeah the guy was impersonating the kid
yeah yeah and he comes back he's like
from like france or some [ __ ] this
happens in america he comes back
and he says he was sex trafficked yeah
and he impersonates their missing child
oh from like a couple in like nebraska
or something somewhere like midwest and
he has a complete crazy accident he has
a french accent and he's like a
grown-ass man kind of yeah i picked it
up while i was getting being sex
trafficked you asked dude what's up it's
me it's your boy it's like years after
dude yeah crazy and then
in that documentary they they kind of
suspect that the parents of the missing
child don't believe killed their kids oh
[ __ ] what like i think that's why
because they're like there's no [ __ ]
way you went mystery and they moved and
then they played it off yeah that's good
to them the kid that's impersonating
doesn't know that he's about to get into
a house full of psychos and he's a
that's a great movie though he's like
i'm about to con this family steve how
does it end yeah dude well it ends like
get out ended
that's it it ends with me knocking on a
door and saying anybody here want to
give me a room job
no that's the after credit third cycle
comes in
that's the after credits that makes you
like one more you're like he's the
creepy brother dude he's the creepy
brother they're all about to kill
themselves with him in the climax joe
watson anybody want to give me a rim job
they're like whoa all right
[Laughter]
i'll just cycle out
you